you might ask
why aren't they looking for us one
possibility is that we are not
interesting like we were talking about
another possibility you know if there
are
millions of or billions of years uh into
their technological development
they created their own their own habitat
their own cocoon where they feel
comfortable they have everything they
need
and it it's risky for them to establish
communication with
other so they have their own cocoon and
they close off
they don't care about anything else now
in that case you might say oh
so how can we find about them if they
are closed off
the answer is they still have to deposit
trash
right that's that is something from the
law of thermodynamics
there must be some production of trash
and
you know we can still find about them
just like investigative journalists
going through the trash cans of
celebrities in hollywood you know
you can learn about the private lives of
those celebrities
by looking at the front it's fascinating
to think you know if if we are the ants
in this picture
if we if this thing is a water bottle or
if it's like a smartphone
like where where on the spectrum of
possible
objects of space because there's a lot
of interesting trash
like where how interesting is this trash
but imagine a caveman
seeing a cell phone the caveman would
think since the caveman
played with rocks all of his life he
would say it's a rock
just like my fellow astronomers said yes
right
exactly that's brilliantly put actually
as a scientist
do you hope it's a water bottle or a
smartphone because a smart i hope it's
even more than a smartphone i hope that
it's something that is really
sophisticated and funny yeah see i'm the
opposite i i feel like i hope it's a
water bottle because
at least we have a hope with our current
set of skills to understand it
yeah caveman has no way of understanding
the smartphone it's like it will be
like i feel like a caveman has more to
learn from the plastic water bottle than
they do from the smartphone but suppose
we figure it out
if we if we for example come close to it
and and
learn what it's made of and i guess the
smartphone is
full of like thousands of different
technologies that we could
probably pick at
you